Brian so you havin this cup of tea Pepi
buddy I made it some bread and no bread
so I just went along well I'll go up to
the shots and get this right and then
this court came down and it had Labor on
and I just said to the police officer
it's God and bragging on that cause and
he says no he's round the corner there
and I said all right wanna have a word
regard and as I got swords it got there
and he was like giving this speech so as
he started to walk towards may I show to
them to us I know I'm absolutely ashamed
of Satyam lib now you mustn't be cheeky
zone another shoe keys on that put me
over and on top of is and I said to him
I said boys thank you for talking to me
so started to walk back down and they
were all waiting for me when he came to
see me after you know you were in a a 45
minutes or talking to he then went to
see the Queen of it was something and
that was only 50 minute he's just been
45 minutes
Gillian nothing
I've just been talking to - Gillian I'm
mortified by what's happened I'd given
her my sincere apologies I misunderstood
what she said some people you know they
still stop me in town and talk to me and
I listen I'm nobody I'm not you know I I
just saw you know that some people say
oh right I won't talking more you know